[Music]
if you're like us you watch the teaser
like 100 times to try to find hidden
clues and messages about descendants 3
we noticed some pretty interesting
details that you might have missed
you're not going to believe what we
discovered at number one want to geek
out with us on all things descendants
subscribe to the things and give us a
big thumbs up and now here are 5 hidden
messages in the descendants 3 teaser you
might have missed the enchanted forest
ok so let's break this down moment by
moment the teaser is only 30 seconds
long but we were able to extract a lot
of information in that brief 30 seconds
like mouths location she appears to be
in some sort of enchanted forest since
there is no magic on the Isle that means
mal is probably in auradon
or maybe the outskirts in descendants to
Audrey called Chad and asked him to come
rescue her in a faraway Sherwood Forest
could that be where we find mal in the
teaser if she's lied on the Isle it's
possible that mouths dad is not a
villain if he was a villain stuck on the
Isle he wouldn't have the magical
ability to make himself into a glowing
smoky orb thing we think that could mean
he's a human in the book Maleficent does
say that she had a moment of weakness
with a feeble human but humans don't
have magical powers so did were live
isn't trapped in the nut flowerpot who
seems like he is trying to escape or
maybe he is sending a message from
somewhere beyond the underworld perhaps
all we know is that the enchanted forest
looks crazy spooky quite an interesting
place to be reunited with her pops
mouths evil attire let's talk fashion
for a second mal appears in this
enchanted forest wearing the same outfit
she was wearing when she returned to the
Isle and descendants to in the
descendants through teaser she's
stepping through the forest and those
sparkling rock star boots tied purple
other pants about 15 shiny belts a
trippy green undershirt and a purple
leather jacket with mini dragon wings on
the back her hair is the same as it was
after dizzy gave her that makeover at
lady Jermaine's curl up and die salon in
the second film dizzy did us all a favor
by returning her to her wicked cool look
that we all loved so much so we think
the hidden message here is that mal is
returning to her evil roots once again
now seems to be conflicted between
she comes from and Russia is becoming
she could be on a quest to find herself
maybe she is seeking answers and finds a
huge missing piece in the puzzle her dad
we're just wondering how she got back
into that outfit after the cotillion
in decisions - somewhere between two
students - and dissonance three she goes
from belle of the ball on a boat to bad
ball beauty in a box we want to know
what inspired this wardrobe change the
inmost cave it's pretty clear that now
has an awesome tribe of misfits to rely
on for friendship so where are they in
the teaser that leads us to hidden
message number three the inmost cave if
you've read the hero's journey you'll
know that in most stories there is a
point at which the hero has to confront
some things about herself and her past
this is usually a reckoning with some
deep inner conflicts that the hero must
face in order to move on and triumph in
the end mal is totally alone in the
spooky forest
there is no Ben no Evie no Jay or Carlos
she is facing this big moment completely
on her own we think that's pretty
significant Mao went off on her own to
the aisle in descendants - but this new
quest seems to be a bit more treacherous
mal has probably been wondering about
her father for a long time what else
would make her wonder out into the dark
woods alone she is seeking something she
wants answers well she came to the right
forest and the teaser she finds herself
in this garden of botanical dads and
even though Maddow is a mysterious
glowing ball she seems to recognize him
or at the very least his voice she calls
him dad like she knows him force field
all right we're not kidding when we said
we watched this teaser like 100 times to
find hidden clues we paused it and went
through it frame by frame and when we
did we discovered another interesting
thing we missed before it seems like
mouths dad closes with a big burst of
energy and mal backs up to protect
herself that's not exactly the warm
inviting hug a girl would expect from
her father which leads us to our next
clue
now his dad can't touch her it's clear
that he is trying to break through to be
able to get to mal but even with that
big flash of light and magic he can't
reach her and she backs up and shields
herself that's not a good sign this
makes us think that mouse dad is trapped
somewhere from which he is desperately
trying to escape
mal seems pretty guarded when her dad's
Forestville
pulsus does Mao have a history with her
dad or did her mom maleficent fill her
head with stories about how awful he was
whatever is happening it seems like a
pretty unnerving encounter with the old
man this dad is going to have to work
even harder than most since he seems to
be without a body at the moment a hidden
face you're not going to believe this
other major clue we found when we slowed
down the teaser and went frame by frame
if you pause it at 23 seconds you'll see
it too it's a hidden face in the smokey
dad orb and if you pause it at 25
seconds you see the face even more
defined but this time it looks like it
has a mustache now seems to recognize
her dad through the smoke and flashing
light but is she responding to his voice
whispering her name or does she see his
face in the glow we narrowed it down and
based this phosphorous face we came up
with with a couple of possibilities for
whom Al's dad is our first guest from
that freeze-frame at 23 seconds is Hades
it kind of looks like him right
and we know fans are speculating about
Hades being maus dad and Tim trying to
communicate with her from the underworld
our other Theory stems from the face we
saw at 25 seconds you know the one with
the mustache that totally looks like
Captain Hook that would make Harry hook
her Hadi half-brother so is now half
pirate or half underworld either way
these two bad dad theories would make
her all evil what do you think and those
are five hidden messages in The
Descendants three teaser you might have
missed find some hidden messages of your
own comment below we'd love to read them
thanks for watching the things see you
next time
[Music]